et puis un soir il y a un type qui est
arrivé
qui nous a regardé qui s'est marré
qui est venu nous voir à la fin du
spectacle qui nous a dit
je vous aime bien vous m'avez fait
marrer j'ai une émission l'année
prochaine qui s'appelle fiesta je
voudrais vous engager et bien ce type
c'était Patrick Sébastien ce type
c'était un prince car un peu changé
notre destin il y a rien que pour ça
j'aurais j'aurais te remercier encore
toujours
mais d'ailleurs tous ceux que j'ai aidés
ils sont tous reconnaissés c'est vrai
que c'est tu te dis que tout est
possible parce que quand je les ai pris
il faisait des sketchs c'est des seaux
d'eau tu vois et un soir j'étais chez
moi je te dois ma télé et je le vois
monter aux Oscars recevoir un Oscar mais
ça veut dire tout est possible
Jean Dujardin bravo